pick up your French English dictionaries
and join a group of battle-hardened
warrior nuns because the only thing
scarier than French zombies is the time
my girlfriend may be watched an entire
season of Emily in Paris you don't speak
French fake it till you make it kill me
right now I don't have a girlfriend The
Walking Dead returns following one of
the franchise's most beloved characters
as he must undergo A Dangerous Mission
across the French Countryside and in
this video we'll be taking a deep dive
into episode 1 and all the clues that
really show just how important this
journey is and make sure to stick around
to the end of the video where we take a
look at the seasoned trailers for hints
on where the series is headed now let's
get into it over black we hear the voice
of Judith who you may remember as the
biological daughter of Lori Grimes and
Shane Walsh and the adopted daughter of
Michonne in Rick Grimes this is played
as we see Daryl Dixon floating somewhere
in the south of France she says you
deserve a happy ending too a line from
the series finale of The Walking Dead
Carol
yeah
you deserve a happy ending too and it
looks like Daryl is far from this happy
ending as he's seemingly stranded at Sea
on the brink of death the last time we
saw Daryl was in The Walking Dead series
finale where he leaves the Commonwealth
in search of answers at the behest of
Maggie I want to talk about the future
there's a lot out there to find out
about and I think it's time you did by
the way if you're curious what Maggie's
been up to after the events of The
Walking Dead I did a whole video on her
spin-off dead city which I'll leave a
link to in the description below now
there's a lot of things Maggie and Daryl
want to know why are the undead changing
how did the outbreak start and is a cure
possible but that still doesn't answer
how Daryl got halfway around the world
fortunately the Walking Dead's World
Beyond spin-off series offers some clues
in its season 2's post-credits scene
here we see Dr Jenner who you may
remember from season one of The Walking
Dead communicating with an abandoned lab
in France there's some French graffiti
that translates to the dead were born
here if Daryl is looking for answers Why
not start with the outbreak supposedly
began Dr Jenner also talks about variant
cohorts in France something they haven't
seen in their labs in the United States
you referred to in our last
communication this may be the key to
understanding how the Walker is known as
wulong came to fruition these variants
have the ability to burn the skin of
those they touch something Daryl finds
out the hard way he washes ashore near
the port city of marsai as we'll see him
uncover tape recordings and a map from
an Irish family as they track their
Voyage to escape the zombie apocalypse
on the map we can see their final
location is Masai after spending 19
months at Sea Dara will even use his
finger to point from the Gulf of kadi to
marsai and it's the Gulf of kadi that
this ship captain will meet at the end
of the episode says he lost Daryl so it
looks like the current swept Daryl all
away from the Gulf here up to the coast
of Southern France all we really know
about how he got here was that there was
some sort of mutiny on a tanker ship and
Daryl escaped now he wants to get back
to America suggesting that he may have
already found what he was looking for
maybe he knows there's no cure which
would explain why he feels so helpless
it ain't my problem he also mentions in
his tape recording if I don't make it
back
I want to know I tried further hinting
that his voyage was a failure this
tanker ship also acted as a research
vessel where Walker test subjects were
experimented on what did Daryl see here
that would cause him to Mutiny and
Destroy years of research with some fish
in his belly Daryl makes his journey to
the port town albuterits and I gotta say
I love these shots of the landscape
including zombie infested Roman
aqueducts something you'd be
hard-pressed to see in America Daryl
doesn't speak French something that
certainly would come in handy if he had
read the sign outside the abandoned
Market where he's attacked the graffiti
reads atencion afma isi which translates
to warning hungry ones inside Isabelle a
nun who will come to help Daryl on his
journey States these hungry ones are
what they call zombies but the most
striking revelation after Daryl takes on
a horde of them are the Bruno Walkers
who have either evolved or were created
that can burn their victims as Isabelle
notes these are but one kind of new very
audience out there and I hope we get to
discover some new ones as the series
continues now Daryl has actually made it
pretty darn far before he comes across
Maribel and Guillaume from this road
sign he's about 15 kilometers from Lord
so we can see from this map
approximately how far he's traveled
there's also this important scene where
Daryl's Snickers at the translation to
do this m God loves you Daryl has no
faith and doesn't believe in God but as
he teams up with Isabel and Lauren later
on expect this to be a part of his
character Arc this season something will
give him that fuel to believe again and
I think that person will be long
Guillaume here plays the blind crippled
man in an attempt to trick Daryl into
getting his supplies but that's not
before the three of them are interrupted
by soldiers working for the cause now I
don't think the name of their group is
explicitly said in this episode I found
that name on a press article so it could
possibly change the cause is some sort
of political movement composed of
soldiers and scientists when one of the
soldiers gets a little too handsy with
Maribel Daryl is quick to set him
straight with Mirabelle showing just how
ruthless she can be that's our first
clue that these two aren't the poor weak
survivors they seem to be Guillaume
knocks Daryl out proving that he's not
really blind or crippled at all luckily
Isabelle is nearby and ushers and
injured Daryl to the nearby Convent
where his wounds are taken care of and
his burn cauterized this convent has
been operating for 12 years and is part
of an alliance of different groups in
face known as Union du Les pois or Union
of hope not much is known about this
Union other than the fact they have safe
houses across Europe have a main base up
north and are led by a Buddhist monk
named Lama rinposh but more on the
importance of this in a bit and before
we go any further just a quick reminder
that if you like these videos and want
me to cover the rest of the season
please like And subscribe every little
bit helps the channel out in a very
weird scene Isabelle the nun washes a
naked Daryl and the two see each other's
scars both come from violent past and it
seems Isabel tried to kill herself by
slitting her wrists Daryl has shown the
medieval weapons room where the nuns are
trained in combat but what Daryl is
really interested in is Father Jean's
radio notice how Isabelle locks the door
not wanting Daryl to go in and find out
the radio she promised he could use
doesn't even work that's because
Isabelle believes Daryl is the messenger
the one who will escort Laurel to the
union of Hope's main base to the north
where he will be taught and trained to
become the new leader of humanity
Isabelle and the nuns believe him to be
the second coming of Christ stating that
his abilities perceptions and compassion
make him special he even drew a picture
of a man who looks a lot like Daryl in
the sea three weeks before Daryl's
arrival grew up in the convent after his
mother died in childbirth father Jean
became like an actual father to him
which is why lorong continues to recite
poetry to the man even after he turned
into a zombie the poem he read is one of
France's most famous called liberte or
Liberty and it was written during the
occupation of France by Germany in World
War II and conveys the importance of
holding on to Freedom it's an app Choice
considering France is under a new
occupation of sorts that of the Walkers
there is definitely something different
with this larong kid he's super
intelligent considerate and says that he
can feel Daryl's sadness he even says
but you deserve a happy ending too the
same thing Judith said to him now is
this all coincidence or is it all really
the second coming of Christ that'll
likely be the big question this season
tries to answer while Daryl may not have
found a medical cure for the virus what
if this cure isn't a sort of vaccine but
rather a person and that person being
Laurel Laurel after all does discuss the
idea of healing asking Daryl how many
generations he'd think it would take to
repopulate France now guillaume's future
is short-lived after he's killed by a
cause Soldier known as kotron he's
looking for the person who killed his
brother one of the soldiers murdered by
Maribel and to save her own hide she
says it was the American who did it when
kudwal sees a God loves you poster at
the scene of the crime he decides to
investigate the Abbey to see if they're
harboring this fugitive meanwhile Daryl
gets his ass as far away from the nuns
believing them to be crazy I mean the
second coming of Christ yeah right they
want him to take the dangerous route
father Jean created to take long up
North but he doesn't want to do this
especially after finding out Isabel lied
to him about the radio but while Daryl
makes his exit he sees a group of
soldiers approach The Abbey and we all
know he's too much of a hero slash nice
guy not to go back and protect this
group of nuns in their search of the
Abbey the soldiers come across father
Jean with codswall threatening to put
the Walker out of its misery should they
not disclose the location of the
American but that no good Laurel gets in
the way pleading for them not to kill
him kudwa orders the child to be taken
to Janae who will see at the end of the
episode and appears to be the cause's
leader this prompts Daryl to stab one of
the soldiers in the back starting an
all-out war between nuns and the cause
now the nuns end up Victorious but not
without several casualties including
Mother Superior who tells Laurel he is
quote the cure for a sick world with the
nuns buried Daryl makes a deal with
Isabel he'll escort them to this Union
camp in the north if Isabelle agrees to
take him to lahav a port where he might
be able to get a ship lahav also happens
to be the ship where Daryl was on has
docked and it has undergone a lot of
damage we can see what looks to be
remnants of a fire on these fenced
windows it's here we meet Janae who
orders her men to hunt down this Daryl
Dixon I also found it really creepy when
Janae puts her hand on the captain's
shoulder and just walks away like she
doesn't kill him or punish him it's just
really really weird and I can't help but
think there's more to that now we get to
the part of the video where I take a
look at the trailers to see if they
offer any Clues on what happens next
note that I won't be covering every shot
just the ones I think will be relevant
going forward in this quick shot we have
Daryl fighting who I believe Are
Soldiers of the cause and if you look
really closely you'll see a sign in the
background that says muster station
which you only really find on large
ships so I think we're gonna have
flashbacks of him escaping that large
tanker and in this next shot you guessed
it he has escaped from the ship we saw
at the end of episode 1. it looks as
though he's being chased by an extremely
fast zombie perhaps one of these new
variants remember the guys on this ship
were conducting experiments on Walker so
who knows what weird variants they've
come up with below here you can see an
explosion of what might be their lab and
if Daryl found out these guys were
responsible for some messed up Creations
I could see him wanting to blow it up
these trailers also give us a glimpse of
Daryl's journey and some of the Exotic
locales he'll be visiting from castles
the Island City of monse Michelle and
Paris just to name a few here we see
Janae the woman from the end of episode
1 who orders could go to hunt down Daryl
this guy is named falu and judging by
the background this might be one of the
safe houses Daryl and the others
encounter on their Journey North now
this is really cool we have Isabel in
the Paris Metro in regular clothes it
looks like we're going to have
flashbacks of her at the start of the
outbreak I'm curious if we'll also see
the death of her sister who she said
also lived in Paris back to present-day
Paris where Daryl and Isabelle walk past
the famous Pantheon building which has
the sign fooye draped over the front the
French word for flee Daryl hands over a
knife to Laurel and we see them Embrace
I think this is going to be at the core
of the season this relationship between
Daryl and this kid now this is Wild is
this Isabelle with a baby if so could
she be Laurel's mother Isabel said
Lauren's mother died in childbirth maybe
she meant a metaphorical death and after
she was born she became a nun that old
her was dead and she became something
new but I'm thinking this is her
sister's child in this brief shot check
out the fabric and color of the hand
near the top right it looks pretty
similar to the sweater Isabelle wears
here my theory is that Isabelle's sister
was pregnant got infected and they had
to operate on her to save the child who
ends up being Laura this would mean
Laurel is Isabelle's nephew cool new
zombie injected with a dart this looks
like it could be one of those variants
and check out all these zombies here it
looks like we're gonna have a big battle
underneath the Eiffel Tower that's
pretty freaking cool I can't wait I'm
really excited for the season I think
it's off to a great start but what did
you think I want to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below
thanks for watching please be sure to
like And subscribe and for more bad
takes you can follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at thinkstory YT until next
time remember kill me right now
foreign